hi there Steve Kaufman here this morning
and today I want to talk about learning
the basics because that always comes up
people said want to learn the basics of
the language the assumption is that
there's some shortcut to learning the
basics if you read the grammar and learn
a bunch of words then you have the
basics so then you can start using the
language and of course as you know I
don't really believe that to be the case
I believe you have to get a lot of the
language in you before you can have a
chance of you know naturally feeling
with the basics of a language are and
therefore I think that the the fastest
way to get to the basics to in a way
break the back off to make a
breakthrough in becoming familiar with
the new language is essentially what
I've been doing with Turkish using the
mini story so I want to kind of show you
a bit of that in you know on the screen
here but the basic principle is that you
know I've been at Turkish now for 1012
days I think Wednesday today's Monday
Wednesday it will be 2 weeks and so on
Thursday I will do sort of a summary of
my first two weeks on Turkish that is I
knew nothing about Turkish nothing and
then you know where am i after two weeks
well first of all you will see that I
have gone through all 60 mini stories
basically that's what I've done I've
explored a few other content items but
I've basically stuck to the many stories
and ice I will show you the early mini
stories because I keep on going back and
going back I've listened to them 10 20
30 times whereas the you know story 50
story 60 I've listened to once or twice
so obviously in stories 1 2 3 4 5 6 also
I've read the first story 6 7 times the
more recent stories have read them once
or twice so obviously I become more
familiar with the early stories however
the key thing is that in doing these
many stories stuff repeats and so words
verbs phrases expressions that start
that first make their appearance in the
early stories they show up later on
again and again because
there is a lot of repetition in these
many stories there is a lot of
repetition within each story because
it's told twice and then there are
questions about the story with the
answers provided but also because the
stories focus on the most common verbs
and also some of the most common you
know on the other hand and because and
sort of conjunctions these also repeat a
lot so what what happens what I'm
finding is that I am getting exposed to
essentially all of the structures of the
language I have some questions about the
structures of the language I have
skimmed a grammar explanation of how
things work in Turkish none didn't
really stick that well but it made me a
little more aware of the kinds of things
that I would come across and now I've
been coming across them how they form
the future how they form the past tense
I've seen these over and over again the
fact that you know whereas we say before
something they say something something
unjú so that before comes afterwards or
saundra after so these would show up
after what it is after so you get used
to this so rather than having an
explanation about word order which
doesn't relate to anything we're
familiar with I have now become familiar
with a lot of things in the language and
now I'm more curious to read up on it
just to confirm the things that I have
come across so so really the repetition
in the stories is not only a repetition
of vocabulary
it's a repetition of tenses and and
grammatical aspects and it's a
repetition of certain phrases you know
and and so if Kedar means until
butt-naked are means how much or to what
extent so you come across you know
phrases that encompass certain words
where if you just learned the word you
wouldn't have had the same exposure to
the phrase that includes that word so in
all of these ways I'm really getting a
handle on the basics of the language and
and the other thing about it is it's
relatively easy to keep doing because
it's fairly mechanical so today I'm
gonna listen to stories thirty and forty
which of course I don't understand very
well so then I'm motivated to going
read against Therese 3240 I have once I
get like I've read all sixty stories so
there are no more blue words but there
are lots of yellow words but the yellow
words in the later stars there might be
18 yellow words words and phrases that I
have saved links whereas in the early
ones that might only be 20 when I get
those down to about 10 then I go in and
review those stories just going through
the flashcards because I've isolated
those words and phrases that continue to
escape me I just can't remember them so
there's many different ways and I think
the key in language learning is to find
things that you can easily do with a bit
of variety so that you're not feeling
all the time that you're doing the same
thing over and over again with no
results so with that I just want to show
you a little bit plus there is a website
where they analyze frequency and the
subject of frequency has come up and and
it's important to remember about
frequency that frequency drops off very
quickly and so therefore the idea that
you can sort of seamlessly continue to
find material that's just that little
bit more difficult is not realistic you
can have a high degree of repetition of
very high frequency words and I mean if
they say that the first 500 words or
accounts for 60% or the first a thousand
words accounts for 70% of any content in
the mini stories as I will show you in
English at least where I can count them
I have counted then there's 17 thousand
words so probably in most languages
there is something in that range of 15
16 17 18 thousand words so if the most
frequent words repeating account for 70%
of that that means that that there's
almost treatment 1,000 words the most
frequent of those will appear I don't
know a thousand times several thousand
times and the least frequent will appear
once or twice all within that first 1000
word list and I'm going to show you that
as well so that the frequency list I
don't see that other than B
aware that the frequency drops off very
quickly and be that any Content you use
to learn from will necessarily have all
of the high-frequency words that you
need so that you don't necessarily need
to focus in on the high-frequency words
you just need to expose yourself to
relatively easy content and do it over
and over and over again now let me show
you that on link hi there
now let's see how this is gonna work
okay so as I said I have experimented
with a few other content items but
basically I've stuck with the many
stories and so let me just have us takes
a little while to open here when I'm in
loom for some reason so let's first of
all look at my playlist so the playlist
let's go back here and go to the
playlist so you know you will see that
Story one here let's see if I can make
this thing work story one I have
listened to 29 times but okay now you
could go there what happens here - no it
won't move okay done there we go
whereas very quickly it's like any
frequency thing you know story 319 times
12 times 11 times and so as I get
further up here I listen to a few other
things but story 30 40 or 38 39 I'd
listen to twice so that's an indication
of and here these other stories I
haven't sort of listened to most of them
that much so so that I have this
tremendous opportunity to get to know
these other stories better if I showed
you how often I've listened of read them
it wouldn't be quite as dramatic but
story one would be
fact I can show you that's well doesn't
really matter story one I would have
read six or seven times and story you
know fifty I've read once or twice so
that's in terms of the level of my
activity now what I wanted to show you
was if I go to this is the full text of
the English many stories and the words
are largely the same and it's
interesting that in that frequency study
that sólo mía my Ukrainian teacher did
she found that the drop-off and
frequency was the same no matter whether
it's you know journalistic or academic
and whether in which language it's all
the same so I think whatever happens in
English is very similar to what happens
in other languages now there is this
website which I recommend called the
lexical tutor Lex cuter dot ca it's a
person called Cobb who works out at the
University of Quebec in Montreal but you
can see here that in the case of English
we have you know the word to appear 741
times ah appear 657 times so it'd be a
similar equivalent but very quickly it
drops off goes from 741 to 188 and
pretty soon like they appears only 75
times and then as we go down here you
know a word that we would think is quite
common like small appears 25 times so
it's already dropped off very much from
741 and if I go down here you'll see
that you know again there's only 9 times
in all these stories
so all I'm demonstrating here is that
the frequency drops off very quickly so
what I am achieving really is not
necessarily that I'm nailing all of the
words although the words are gradually
becoming clearer to me rather it's now
rather it's the fact that I'm being
exposed to the different forms of these
words and being exposed to the two
phrases and so forth I could for example
go into my vocabulary area by the way
and I could review just the words that
I've saved the rather learned the known
words or I can review my category three
words or whatever but that's not what I
wanted to show you so if I go into my
mini stories I am going to continue with
them and you'll see that here in mini
story won't have 17 links or saved words
and phrases 1619 but as I go down the
list it starts to build pretty quickly
by the time I met Story 24 it's 33 45 52
3946 so as I go forward I those numbers
will drop on these stories so I'm it's
almost sort of a mechanical task I want
to get in there I want to reduce the
number of words that I have once
encountered in order to make them known
and if I do that then if I look at my
profile here I know that I let that load
here so I know that okay laughs this is
my activity over the last week insofar
as known words is concerned obviously
yeah I haven't added as many known words
as I would like although I certainly
beat my I certainly beat my goals but if
I look at my last two weeks so I have
nine hundred and sixty-four known words
three thousand links those are those
yellow links now I am convinced that you
know I've only been at it for less than
two weeks once you know after a month
that number these 3101 links many of
them will convert
words will become learned how many I
don't know but potentially over two
months I'm I think that most of those
will become known so that even if I
don't explore new material which I will
because you know that one of the big
issues in language learning is to keep
you know maintain some variety so at
some point I will start exploring new
content which will mean that I'll create
new links but and I may create links of
phrases but there's a very good chance
that a lot of these 3,000 links will
become known words so that is two months
I don't know how long but I will have
three thousand words
or four thousand words but what's more
important is that during this period
like in in less than two weeks I have
listened to 16 hours of this material 16
hours of listening to the basic words
phrases grammatical structures you know
some of them because therefore since
these kinds of words 16 hours I've
listened to them I've read 40,000 words
now a book is now what that means is
that I have read you know because
there's only 17,000 words in the many
stories roughly so I've read you know
two and a half times that because I've
read them so many times but by the time
I'm done even done with the many stories
I will probably be closer to a hundred
thousand words of reading and maybe
fifty hours of listening and I'll have
all these known words so that the basics
of the language the basic structures I'm
coming across them all the time the
future the wood the so called modal wood
I had - all of these things are showing
up and all of the things that are unique
the turkish are showing up so that you
know I will be reviewing the grammar
explanations of why this is happening
but at the same time I'm absorbing the
basics of the language now once I have
let's say after the first three months
you know some level of comfort of the
basics of the language then of course
the long road towards comfort in the
language begins because then I have to
acquire a lot of vocabulary but even
with what I have now there are in any
language words related words words that
change so you be you achieve this level
of familiarity in other words the basics
I don't nail down the basis I can't
produce them at some point I have to
start speaking and I will
and then I will discover you know all
the things that I am missing but I have
a level of understanding even now of the
basics of Turkish and in another two
weeks in another couple of months that
sense of the basics will be even
stronger and that will give me a strong
basis from which to continue exploring
the language and I think that these two
weeks that I've spent with Turkish and I
put in I have to admit now you know that
listening is free because I do that
while doing other tasks but I am quite
deliberately reading as well as
listening and linking so that I'm
spending more than two hours a day
however if during the same two-week
period I had gone to a university
turkish course and had even you know a
lesson a day so I would have also spent
that much time I would not be as far
ahead so therefore I very much recommend
this as an approach to mastering the
basics or achieving a breakthrough in
the basics of a new life so there you
have it you know my approach to language
learning the basic principle is the same
has always been heavy emphasis on input
reading and listening but since we
started these many stories I have found
this to be you know has accelerated my
learning significantly and in the next
video that I do on Thursday I will show
you how I use the many stories to work
on my pronunciation and to prepare
myself for speaking
and that after all speaking is also part
of the basics but the speaking to my
mind comes after you have some level of
familiarity with the language without
that you can't start speaking you don't
understand you have no words you have no
phrases you not have no sense of the
language so I'll show you that on
Thursday thank you for listening and if
you have any comments please don't
hesitate as I know you don't buy
you